GOOD
AFTERNOON. PLEASE BE SEATED.
THE HOUR OF NOON HAVING ARRIVED
AND PURSUANT TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE ORGANIZATIONAL
SESSION FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO REGULAR SESSION
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY WILL
BE IN ORDER. I AM C. PARKER THE
ASSEMBLY CHIEF CLERK. THE
SPEAKER HAS ORDERED THE
CONVENING OF TODAY SAYS OUT OF
THE STATE K. BUILDING AFTER CAN
WITH SACRAMENT COUNTY TO. OF
SERVICE. AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFF. PURSUANT TO THE ASSEMBLY
RULES SIGN OF CELL PHONES IN A
LIKE DEVICE DURING TODAY'S. THE
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS IS A
ROLL CALL OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ELECT. THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. BARRICADE HAND.
BENNETT BERMAN. BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA. BURKE
CALDERON. CORREO CERVANTES.
SHALL CHEN. CHIU CHOI. COOLEY
COOPER. CUNNINGHAM DALLY. DALY
DAVIES FLORA. FONG FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL. GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GONZALEZ. GREAT GRAYSON.
HOLDEN IRWIN. JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER. KILEY LACKEY.
LEAD LEVINE. LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS. MAYES MCCARTY. MEDINA
MULLIN. MURATSUCHI THIS AREA.
WHEN O'DONNELL. PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK. QUIRK
SILVA. RAMOS RENDON. RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO. SALAS SANTIAGO
C. R. TO. SMITH STONE. TEEN
VALIDATORS BE APPROVED BY A-
VOEPEL. WALDRON WARD. WEBER
WICKS WOOD. A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITHOUT OBJECTION I REQUEST
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER ELECT
RHEOSTAT PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR SHALL BE GRANTED. WE ASK
THE MEMBERS ELECT AND ATTENDEES
TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER
AND THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
THE AFTERNOONS PRAYER WILL BE
GIVEN BY IMAM MUHAMMAD YASIR
KHAN THE PRESIDENT AND FOUNDER
OF ALL MEETHA A CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATION IN ELK GROVE THE
PROVIDE COMMUNITY EDUCATION AND
YOUTH PROGRAMS AS WELL AS A
REFUGEE ASSISTANCE. IMAM YES
SIR.
IN THE NAME OF GOD. THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
HOW MUCH REGARD. WE ASK YOU TO
BESTOW US WITH YOUR LOVE AND
MERCY. THAT ALLOWS US TO LOVE
AND MERCY FOR YOUR CREATION.
INCREASE US AND OUR LOVE FOR
OUR FELLOW CALIFORNIANS. AND
MADE INCREASE WITH EVERY
HEARTBEAT WE HAVE IN OUR CHESTS
AND EVERY BREATH THAT WE TAKE
FOR THE REST OF OUR LIVES I
MEAN.
PLEASE CONTINUE STANDING
AND JOIN THE MEMBERSHIP IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE WILL BE LED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ELECTED
WALDRON. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
AS WE SALUTE THE FLAG TO OUR
GREAT NATION. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE. WITH LIBERTY.
PLEASE BE SEATED. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE ABSENCES FOR
TODAY WILL BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL THE NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS A CERTIFICATE OF
ELECTION FROM THE SECRETARY OF
STATE WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
CERTIFICATE OF ELECTION
DESIGNATING THE DULY ELECTED
MEMBERS SHALL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE DAILY
JOURNAL. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ADMINISTERING THE OATH OF
OFFICE TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ELECT. THE PROCESS FOR
ADMINISTERING THE OATH IS
REFERRED TO AS A ROLE BY
COUNTIES. IT'S A PROCESS THAT
DATES BACK TO EIGHTEEN FIFTY
TWO. THE READING CLERK WILL
READ A LIST OF ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN ALPHABETICAL ORDER.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ELECT
REPRESENTING THAT COUNTY OR
COUNTIES SHOULD STAND AND
REMAIN STANDING UNTIL THE ROLE
IS COMPLETED. THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL BY COUNTY.
ALAMEDA. ALPINE. AMADOR. YOU.
CALAVERAS. COLUSA. CONTRA COSTA.%
BILL NEWARK. ELDORADO. FRESNO.
GLENN. HUMBOLDT. IMPERIAL. INYO.
KERN. KINGS. LAKE. LASSEN. LOS
ANGELES. MADERA. MARIN.
MARIPOSA. MENDOCINO. MERCED.
MODOC. MONNOT. MONTEREY. NAPA.
NEVADA. ORANGE. PLASTER. PLUMAS.
RIVERSIDE. SACRAMENTO. SAN
BENITO. SAN BERNARD DINO. SAN
DIEGO. SAN FRANCISCO. SAN
JOAQUIN. SAN LUIS OBISPO. SAN
MATTEO. SANTA BARBARA. SANTA
CLARA. SANTA CRUZ. SHASTA.
SIERRA. SISKIYOU. SOLANO.
SANOMA. STANISLAUS. SUTTER. TO
HAMMER. TRINITY. TULARE. TO ALL
THE ME. VENTURA. YOLO YUBA. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ADMINISTERING
THE OATH OF OFFICE TO ALL
MEMBERS SIMULTANEOUSLY. MEMBERS
ELECT FOR THE OFFICE OF MEMBER
OF THE ASSEMBLY PLEASE RAISE
YOUR RIGHT HAND AND REPEAT
AFTER ME. I STATE YOUR NAME. I
DO SOLEMNLY SWEAR. THAT I WILL
SUPPORT AND DEFEND. THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES. AND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC. THAT I WILL BEAR TRUE
FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE. TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES. AND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT I
TAKE THIS OBLIGATION FREELY.
WITHOUT ANY MENTAL RESERVATION.
OR PURPOSE OF EVASION. AND THEN
I WILL WELL AND FAITHFULLY.
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES. UPON
WHICH I'M ABOUT TO ENTER.
CONGRADULATIONS MEMBERS. YOU
MAY BE SEATED AND MEMBERS
PLEASE SIGN THE OATH OF OFFICE
WHICH ARE LOCATED IN THE BLUE
FOLDER ON THE DEATH. BEFORE YOU.
THE NEXT. ORDER OF BUSINESS. IS
THE NOMINATION AND ELECTION OF
THE SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO REGULAR SESSION. MEMBERS
GIVING THE NOMINATING AND
SECONDING SPEECHES SHOULD GO TO
THE PRESENTER PODIUM WHEN I
CALL YOUR NAME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON. THE NOMINATIONS ARE
NOW OPEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON. MADAM CLERK AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
NOMINATE ANTHONY RENDON AS
SPEAKER OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY. COLLEAGUES WE HAVE
BEEN GRANTED THE HONOR TO
REPRESENT OUR RESPECTIVE
DISTRICTS BY THE VOTERS AND
WITH THE- THE WE HAVE JUST
TAKEN THAT RESPONSIBILITY NOW
RESTS UPON US TO BE THE VOICE
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS HAS A VOICE
OF ONE SOMETIMES THAT
RESPONSIBILITY IT CAN BE
LIKENED TO A BARKING DOG AT A
SPEEDING LOCOMOTIVE. THAT IS
WHY IT IS IMPERATIVE TO HAVE A
STRONG AND PROVEN LEADER WHO
KNOWS THE VALUE OF THE
COLLECTIVE VOICE OF
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP
IT IS SAID THAT A LEADER WITH
NO ONE FOLLOWING IS SIMPLY A
PERSON TAKING A WALK IN THE
PARK WELL IT HAS BEEN ANYTHING
BUT A WALK IN THE PARK FOR
SPEAKER RENDON THE PAST FEW
YEARS. UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP THE
STATE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
WAS EXTENDED. THE STATE MINIMUM
WAGE WAS INCREASED A LANDMARK
FIFTY TWO BILLION DOLLAR
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING PLAN WAS
PASSED. CALIFORNIA'S CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM WAS EXTENDED. A
FIRST OF ITS KIND REGULATION OF
PREDATORY LENDING HISTORIC
RENTER PROTECTIONS AN IMPORTANT
HOUSING LEGISLATION WERE ALL
PASSED. ON TOP OF ALL THAT. WE
WERE THRUST INTO TERRITORY
UNLIKE ANY OF US HAVE
EXPERIENCED BEFORE. YET ANTHONY
RENDON EXERCISED LEADERSHIP. BY
BALANCING THE SAFETY OF EIGHTY
MEMBERS AND HUNDREDS OF STAFF.
WITH THE NEED TO CONDUCT THE
CENTRAL BUSINESS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. DECISIONS WERE
MADE ABOUT HOW TO PRESERVE THE
CRITICAL SERVICES THAT MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS RELY ON. WHILE
STILL PREPARING FOR AN
UNCERTAIN FUTURE AND LIVING
BUDGETARY SHORTFALL. SPEAKER
RENDON WAS ABLE TO NAVIGATE
THESE CHALLENGES WITH
THOUGHTFULNESS AND GRACE FOR A
SIMPLE REASON. HE IS GUIDED BY
A STRONG SET OF VALUES AND A
CLEAR LEADERSHIP PHILOSOPHY.
MEMBER EMPOWERMENT IS NOT JUST
A CATCH PHRASE TO HIM. IT IS A
PHILOSOPHY OF LEADERSHIP AND
GOVERNANCE THAT HAS INFORMED
HIS DECISION MAKING THROUGHOUT
HIS TENURE AS SPEAKER. IT HAS
SHAPED THE WAY THAT THIS HOUSES
FUNCTION AND IT HAS GIVEN US
THE ECONOMY THAT WE NEED TO
SERVE OR CONSTITUENTS IN THE
WAY WE THINK BEST. NEVER HAS
THE NEED FOR THIS APPROACH BEEN
MORE EVIDENT THAN IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WE NOW FIND
OURSELVES IN. THROUGH
EXTRAORDINARY TIMES AND
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES
SPEAKER RENDON HAS SERVED THIS
HOUSE. ITS MEMBERS AND THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WITH HONOR
INTEGRITY AND FORTITUDE FOR
THESE REASONS I NOMINATE AT
RENDON RENDON FOR SPEAKER AND
ASK THAT YOU GIVE HIM YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON IS
THERE A SECOND. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
TO SECOND THE NOMINATION. THANK
YOU MADAM CLERK IN MEMBERS I AM
PROUD TO RISE TO SECOND THE
NOMINATION OF ANTI RENDON AS
SPEAKER OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY. THIS UNPRECEDENTED
GLOBAL EPIDEMIC PANDEMIC HAS
EXPOSED MANY OF THE BONE
ABILITIES AND IT EQUITIES IN
OUR SYSTEM. CALIFORNIANS ARE
LOOKING TO US TO HELP ADDRESS
HEALTHCARE JOB OPPORTUNITIES
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND MOST IMPORTANT RACIAL
INEQUITIES. WHO WE SELECT AS
OUR LEADER IS NOW MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER TO HELP
GUIDE US THROUGH THESE CRUCIAL
AND CRITICAL CONVERSATIONS.
UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP OVER THE
PAST FOUR YEARS SPEAKER RENDON
HAS LET THIS BODY AND PASSING
LANDMARK PROGRESS APOLOGIES
POLICIES WITH BOTH HIS SUPPORT
IN ADVOCACY. PETER RENDON HAS
ROUTINELY SHOWN THE COURAGE TO
DEAL WITH. AND LOOK TO DEAL
WITH. BILLS THAT REQUIRE MORE
TIME AND EFFORT TO IMPROVE EVEN
WHEN FACING PRESSURE TO DO
OTHERWISE. MISTER SPEAKER STOOD
FIRMLY BY HIS COMMITMENT TO
EMPOWERING HIS COMMITTEE CHAIRS
AND LISTENING TO THE CONCERNS
OF HIS MEMBERS AT THE CHAIR OF
A COMMITTEE MYSELF I HAVE FIRST
HAND EXPERIENCE OF THE TRUST
THE SPEAKER HAS PLACED IN US TO
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISIONS FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. ESPECIALLY
OVER THIS PAST YEAR WE WERE
FACED WITH DIFFICULT DECISIONS
GIVEN OUR WORKFLOW CAPACITY AND
BUDGET CONSTRAINTS. BAKER RUDEN
RENDON HAS TIME AND TIME AGAIN
DISPLAYED INCREDIBLE DEDICATION
TO PROTECTING AND SUPPORTING
HIS MEMBERS. SOMETHING THAT
MANY OF US CAN ATTEST TO.
PERHAPS NO ONE IN THIS CHAMBER
IS MORE AWARE OF THE SPEAKER
EFFORT TO PROTECT MEMBERS OF
THIS BODY. THEY MAKE. THERE
COUPLE A MILLION REASONS WHY
SHOULDN'T BE HERE. SPEAKER
RENDON FROM THIS POEM THAT I
LEARNED IN COLLEGE INVICTUS.
MADE ME INVINCIBLE AND THE
ABILITY TO BE HERE IT IS THE
SPEAKERS. MANDATE WHEN IT WHEN
HE'S BEHIND YOU HE'S BEHIND YOU.
IN THE IN THE POEM INVICTUS IS
SET OUT IN THE NIGHT THAT
COVERS ME BLACK AS THE PIT FROM
POLE TO POLE I THANK WHATEVER
GODS THERE MAY BE FOR MY
UNCONQUERABLE SOUL. THERE WERE
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T
BELIEVE THAT I WOULD BE HERE
TODAY. AND IN THAT POEM IS
TALKS ABOUT SOMEBODY BEAT IN
THE DUNGEON. AND THEIR LAST
BREATH. BUT THEY KEPT THEIR
HEAD UP HIGH. IT ENDS WITH
BEYOND THIS PLACE OF WRATH AND
TEARS LOOMS BUT THE HORROR THAT
THE SHADE. AND YET THE MENACE
OF THE YEARS FINDS AND SHALL
FIND ME UNAFRAID. IT ENDS WITH
I AM THE MASTER OF MY FATE. I
AM THE CAPTAIN OF MY SOUL EACH
OF US IS THE MASTER OF OUR OWN
FATE. BUT WE NEED A CAPTAIN.
TWO LEADING THE SPEAKERSHIP A
CAPTAIN. THAT WILL MAKE SURE
THAT THIS ASSEMBLY MEETS ALL
THE CRITICAL CHALLENGES THAT
ARE COMING UP. AS WE ENTER INTO
THIS SESSION. OUR SPEAKERS
PROVEN LEADERSHIP WILL BE
CRUCIAL IN THIS BODY SUCCESS ON
BEHALF. OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
HE'S THE CAPTAIN OF THE SHIP.
IT WOULD BE A TITANIC MISTAKE
IF WE DID NOT REELECT ANTHONY
RENDON AS SPEAKER OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SECOND THE
NOMINATION. MADAM CLERK AND
MEMBERS I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THE MOTION FOR ANTHONY RENDON
TO CONTINUE AS OUR SPEAKER.
HAVING JUST COMPLETED MY FIRST
TERM AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
AS SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS THE
DISTRICT THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
HELD BY MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS I CAN
HONESTLY SAY THAT THE SPEAKERS
LEADERSHIP MADE WHAT COULD HAVE
BEEN A DIFFICULT TRANSITION SO
MUCH EASIER. HIS ACCESSIBILITY
AND SUPPORT WHEN IT CAME TO
ENSURING THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO SERVE MY DISTRICT
ENABLE ME TO FOCUS MY ATTENTION
ON BEING AN EFFECTIVE
LEGISLATORS AND REPRESENTATIVES.
AS A PARENT OF TWO YOUNG
FLEXIBILITY AND RESPONSIVENESS
WHEN IT COMES. TO ADAPTING TO
THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES THAT
THOSE OF US WITH KIDS FACE AS
LEGISLATORS. CHALLENGES HE
KNOWS PERSONALLY. WHEN I
APPROACHED HIM AND HIS TEAM OF
SUGGESTIONS ABOUT HOW TO MAKE
OUR HOUSE FRIENDLIER FOR
WORKING PARENTS MY SUGGESTIONS
HAVE BEEN HEARD AND TO A LARGE
DEGREE IMPLEMENTED. HE IS
AFFORDED US THE TIME TO CARE
FOR FAMILIES WHILE ENSURING WE
HAVE THE SUPPORT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THE IMPORTANT WORK. WE
HAVE TO THE OLD TO HEAR. BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY IN MY
PROFESSIONAL LIFE. I KNOW HOW
RARE IT IS TO FIND A TRUE
SERVANT LEADERS. ESPECIALLY IN
THE POLITICAL WORLD. AND I
CERTAINLY CAN EXPECT WHEN I
CAME TO THE SIMPLY THAT I WOULD
FIND IT AND OUR SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON. SPEAKER RENDON IS ONE
OF THOSE RARE SERVANT LEADERS
WHO PUTS THE NEEDS OF THE TEAM
OF OUR HOUSE. ABOVE HIS OWN.
HIS LEADERSHIP STYLE RELIES ON
EMPOWERING LEGISLATORS RATHER
THAN OVERPOWERING US. HE WORKS
HARD TO ENSURE THAT ALL VOICES
ARE HEARD WELCOMES DISSENTING
VIEWS AND HAS NO RESERVATIONS
ABOUT OTHERS LEADING THE WAY ON
ISSUES. THIS IS ENABLED US TO
MAXIMIZE THE INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY. AND OUR STATE
RESULTING IN SOME CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF OUR MOST
SERIOUS PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA
AND THAT WE'RE FACING BEFORE
AND ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT WILL
COME. THAT MEMBERS IS WHY HIS
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP IS SO
CRITICAL AT THIS TIME. WITH
CALIFORNIA IN THE THROES OF A
PANDEMIC. AND A LONG ECONOMIC
RECOVERY TO COME WE NEED
SOMEONE WHO ENCOURAGES NEW
IDEAS AND EMPOWER EVERYONE
AROUND HIM TO MAKE A
CONTRIBUTION. MADAM CLERK IN
MEMBERS I SECOND THE NOMINATION
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER ANTHONY
RENDON DICKINSON HERE CONTINUE
TO SERVE AS OUR SPEAKER. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SECOND THE
NOMINATION. THANK YOU MADAM
CLERK AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO SECOND THE NOMINATION OF
ANTHONY RENDON AS SPEAKER OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
SPEAKER RENDON WILL AND HAS
EMPOWER THIS BODY AND THE
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY. AND
IMPERIAL SPEAKER HE IS NOT. HE
EMPOWERS MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE
CHAIRS TO REPRESENT THEIR
DISTRICTS AND POLICY AGENDAS
WITHOUT INTERFERENCE. THIS
BOTTOM UP APPROACH IS COUNTER
TO WHAT SOME OUTSIDE THIS
ELECTED BODY MAY DESIRE. BUT IT
IS GOOD FOR THE INSTITUTION AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE VALUES OF
THE STATE'S FOUNDING FATHERS
AND MOTHERS. MR RENDON
REPRESENTS A DISTRICT JUST TO
THE NORTH OF ME HE IS PRESENT
IN HIS DISTRICT AND REPRESENTS
IT WITH PRIDE. ABILITY AND
UNDERSTANDING. HIS DISTRICT HAS
MANY FAMILIES THAT ARE
IMMIGRANTS AND MANY OF THE
POLICIES THIS BODY HAS ADOPTED
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS OUR
DIRECT RESULT OF HIS
UNDERSTANDING OF HIS DISTRICT
AND THE NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE
THAT LIVE IN IT. MOST TO GREW
UP OR GROWING UP MUCH LIKE HIM.
WITHOUT THE QUALIFICATION I
SECOND THAT NOMINATION OF
ANTHONY RENDON TO BE SPEAKER OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
HE IS A CLASS ACT LISTEN AND
CARES GREATLY ABOUT THIS
INSTITUTION AND THE GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MADAM
CLERK AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF DONALD.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON YOUR
RECOGNIZED TO SECOND THE
NOMINATION. MADAM CHIEF CLERK
IN MEMBERS IT IS MY HONOR TO
STAND IN SECOND THE NOMINATION
OF ANTHONY RENDON TO CONTINUE
AS SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY.
THIS IS ALSO MY FIRST OFFICIAL
ACT REPRESENTING MY
CONSTITUENTS. MISTER TOM AND
GLORIA RENDON ANTHONY'S PARENTS.
I WRITE THE NOMINATION OF MR
RENDON BECAUSE I BELIEVE THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT VOTE FOR
LEGISLATOR IF HIS OR HER VOTE
ON THE STATE BUDGET AND WHO
LEADERS IN THAT PROCESS. THE
BUDGET REFLECTS WHO WE ARE AS
INDIVIDUALS AND WHO WE ARE AS A
STATE. IT REPRESENTSOUR
PERSONAL VALUES AND THE
PROMISES MADE TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT SENTENCE HERE
TODAY. THERE CAN BE NO BUDGET
WITHOUT AN ASSEMBLY SPEAKER
SKILLED IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND LOYAL TO THE PUBLIC TRUST
PLACED IN OUR CHARGE. AS
SPEAKER MR RENDON HAS OVERSEEN
THE ADOPTION OF FOR MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET. IN HIS
FIRST YEAR SPEAKER HE PRODUCED
A BALANCED BUDGET ON TIME WHICH
INVESTED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION. IN HIS SECOND YEAR
SPEAKER HE LED THIS BODY IN
PASSING LEGISLATION TO SOLVE
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
CRISIS BEST APPLE SCREEN THE
FIRST SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
STATE TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
AND DECADE. BUILDING ON HIS
EARLIER WORK IN AUTHORING
PROPOSITION ONE A SEVEN POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR WATER BOND
HE LED THIS BODY IN THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO REPAIR THE OROVILLE
DAM SPILLWAY. WHICH GAVE AWAY
FORCING OVER A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE TO
EVACUATE AND CREATED AN ONGOING
THREAT TO THEIR LIVES AND
PROPERTY. AS YOU MAY KNOW. MY
PUBLIC SERVICE CAREER STARTED
AS A STAFF MEMBER FOR SPEAKER
WILLIE BROWN. MISTER BROWN
ALWAYS SAID MY ONLY
CONSTITUENCY IS THE EIGHTY
MEMBERS OF THIS HOUSE. WHEN MR
RENDON BECAME SPEAKER HE PUT IT
THIS WAY. I WANT EACH OF YOU TO
ACHIEVE THE BEST AND THE MOST
FOR THE PEOPLE YOU REPRESENT. I
BELIEVE EVERYONE HERE TO
RESERVE AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
THEY CAN ADVOCATE FORCEFULLY
FOR THEIR IDEAS AND THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. MR RENDON I
UNDERSTAND AND RESPECT EVERY
MEMBERS RESPONSIBILITY AT THE
VANGUARD FOR THEIR DISTRICTS
AND FOR THE PUBLIC TRUST. I
BELIEVE HIS STAYED TRUE TO THAT
PROMISE. IN HIS TIME AS SPEAKER
HIS HELP MEMBERS CHANGE THE
FACE OF CALIFORNIA TO ONE THAT
IS MORE DIVERSE COMPASSIONATE
AND CHEST. WHEN EVERYONE
SHELTERED IN PLACE MR RENDON
WAS IN THE CAPITAL AVAILABLE TO
ALL MEMBERS STATE AGENCIES AND
THE GOVERNOR TO HELP FIGHT THE
PANDEMIC HOWEVER. HE STILL
FOUND TIME TO PARTICIPATE IN
ASSUME MEETING WITH THE
GOVERNMENT CLASS FROM HIS
COLLEGE ALMA MATER. HE WAS
ASKED HOW THE PANDEMIC AFFECTED
HIS RESPONSIBILITIES AS SPEAKER.
HE RESPONDED WELL NORMALLY
THERE ARE AT LEAST ELEVEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE WORKING IN THE
CAPITAL ON ANY GIVEN DAY. NOW
THERE ARE SEVEN PEOPLE AND ME.
I'M NOT SURPRISED THAT MR
RENDON MADE TIME FOR THESE
PEOPLE BECAUSE HE DID THE SAME
FOR ME. MY MOM RECENTLY TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COKE IN NINETEEN.
AND SHE WAS HOSPITALIZED I TOLD
NO ONE OUTSIDE MY FAMILY. I WAS
AT HOME WAITING FOR AN UPDATE
FROM THE HOSPITAL AND MY PHONE
RANG. IT WAS MR RENDON. HE SAID
LISA I AM SO SORRY TO HEAR
ABOUT YOUR MOM HOW CAN I HELP
TELL ME WHAT I CAN DO TO
SUPPORT YOU. LUCKILY MY MOM IS
GETTING BETTER BUT THAT MOMENT
TOLD ME SO MUCH ABOUT THE MAN.
THAT HE WOULD TAKE TIME TO CALL
AND CHECK ON ME AND OFFER HIS
SUPPORT. HE'S NOT FORGOTTEN WHY
HE WENT INTO PUBLIC SERVICE.
AND HE KNOWS THAT EACH OF US
CHOSE TO RUN. BECAUSE THOUGH WE
FEEL THE UNCERTAINTY AROUND
THIS. WE WANT TO FIGHT FOR A
BETTER LIFE FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
MR RENDON HAS PROVEN HIS SKILL
EXPERIENCE AND COMPASSION AND
STRENGTH TO LEAD. I AM HONORED
AND PROUD TO SECOND THE
NOMINATION OF ANTHONY RENDON
FOR SPEAKER BECAUSE HE IS THE
KIND OF LEADER THAT CAN HELP US
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN OTHER
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND THE RIGHT
PERSON TO LEAD US THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS YOUR
RECOGNIZED TO SECOND THE
NOMINATION. THANK YOU MADAM
CLERK MEMBERS. SO TODAY IT IS
MY HONOR. TO RE NOMINATE
ANTHONY RENDON AS SPEAKER OF
THIS ASSEMBLY. I WANT TO BEGIN
BY ACKNOWLEDGING WHAT EVERYONE
HERE KNOWS. WHAT WE CAN SEE
JUST BY LOOKING AROUND. THIS IS
BEEN AN UNUSUAL YEAR. IT'S BEEN
A HARD YEAR. AND WE OUGHT TO BE
PROUD OF THE WORK THAT THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY HAS
ACCOMPLISHED. DESPITE THIS
BEING ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING LEGISLATIVE PERIODS
IN STATE HISTORY. WE'VE TAKEN
ACTION TO PROTECT SMALL
BUSINESSES. TO PROVIDE PAID
MEDICAL LEAVE FOR WORKERS WHO.
BEEN POSITIVE COVER NINETEEN.
AND WE'VE COVERED THE TESTING
AND TREATMENT FOR THE UNINSURED.
WE'VE SECURED THE BILLIONS IN
FUNDING FOR OUR SCHOOLS. NOT TO
MENTION THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE
ON OTHER IMPORTANT ISSUES FROM
THE GROWING PROBLEM OF
HOMELESSNESS. TO ENSURE IN OUR
STATE FIREFIGHTERS HAVE THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED. THIS
NEXT YEAR IN SESSION. IS GOING
TO BRING MORE CHALLENGES. SOME
WE CAN ANTICIPATE. AND SOME WE
CANNOT. AND AS WE FACE WHAT'S
COMING WE NEED A STEADY HAND WE
NEED A LEADER. A LEADER WITH
EXPERIENCE. A LEADER WHO
LISTENS AND EMPOWERS EACH ONE
OF US TO GET THINGS DONE. WE
ALL HAVE STORIES OF WORKING
WITH SPEAKER RENDON TO ACHIEVE
OUR GOALS. UNDER THIS SPEAKER.
WE HAVE SET TRENDS TRENDS THAT
THE NATION FOLLOWS THAT AS WE
HAVE HEARD. A FIFTEEN DOLLAR
MINIMUM WAGE OVERTIME WAGES FOR
FARMWORKERS AN EFFORT THAT WAS
A BOLD STEP TOWARDS JUSTICE.
EXTENSION OF CAP AND TRADE AN
AMBITIOUS NEW CLIMATE GOALS.
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
TRANSPORTATION. A PERMANENT
FUNDING SOURCE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. A STATE WIDE USE OF
FORCE STANDARD FOR POLICE
OFFICERS A STANDARD THAT WAS IN
EXAMPLE. THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY. THE SPEAKER HAS MADE
THESE ACHIEVEMENTS AND MANY
MANY OTHERS. AND HE'S DONE SO
HE'S MADE THESE ACHIEVEMENTS
POSSIBLE. HE'S DONE IT BY
EMPOWERING MEMBERS. BY BUILDING
COALITIONS AND CONSENSUS. HE IS
THE GRANDSON OF MEXICAN
IMMIGRANTS. HE'S WORKED MANUAL
LABOR. AND THAT WAS. BEFORE HE
EARNED HIS DEGREES ONE FROM ONE
OF OUR GREAT STATE UNIVERSITIES
CSU. FULLERTON I BELIEVE. AND
THEN A PHD FROM ANOTHER UC
RIVERSIDE. HE LED THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. HE LET A
CHILD DEVELOPMENT NONPROFIT AND
WHEN THE STATE CUT EDUCATION
FUNDING HE RAN FOR OFFICE AND
HE RAN FOR OFFICE TO FIGHT FOR
KIDS. THIS IS A MAN WHO
EMBODIES. WHAT YOU DREAM. FROM
HUMBLE I'M A HUMBLE START. TO A
COMMUNITY LEADER THE SPEAKER OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
HIS LIFE HAS GIVEN HIM EMPATHY
FOR PEOPLE OF ALL BACKGROUNDS.
AS WELL AS A DEEP UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT IS POSSIBLE IN THIS
STATE. WHAT MUST CONTINUE TO BE
POSSIBLE IN OUR GREAT STATE.
THIS NEXT TERM WILL BE
CHALLENGING BUT I'M ABSOLUTELY
CONFIDENT HAT UNDER SPEAKER
RENDON'S STEADY LEADERSHIP. WE
WILL HONOR THE PRICE THAT HAS
BEEN PLACED IN EACH ONE OF US.
WE WILL HELP LEAD OUR STATE OUT
OF THESE CHALLENGING TIMES. AND
WE WILL KEEP WORKING TOWARDS
GREATER EQUALITY GREATER
JUSTICE AND GREATER OPPORTUNITY
FOR EVERY SINGLE CALIFORNIA.
FOR HIS RECORD OF ACHIEVEMENT
FOR HIS COMMITMENT TO
PROTECTING THE CALIFORNIA DREAM.
I AM VERY PROUD TO RE NOMINATE
ANTHONY RENDON FOR SPEAKER
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS ARE THERE
FURTHER NOMINATIONS FOR THE
OFFICES SPEAKER THIS FAMILY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY YOUR
RECOGNIZED. I RISE TO NOMINATE
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FROM SAN
DIEGO MARIE WALDRON TO BE THE
NEXT SPEAKER OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY. REGARDLESS OF
PARTY AFFILIATION IDEOLOGICAL
MEANING. OR INTEREST GROUP
ATTACHMENTS. I'D URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR
A SIMPLE REASON. SHE ACTUALLY
WANTED TO WORK THIS YEAR. SHE
ACTUALLY BELIEVED WE SHOULD
HAVE A LEGISLATIVE BRANCH. AT A
TIME OF EXCEPTIONAL CHALLENGES
FOR STATE GOVERNMENT SHE
THOUGHT THAT A STATE LAWMAKERS
WE SHOULD BE EXPECTED TO GOVERN.
MANY OF US FELT THE SAME WAY.
WE CALLED ON THE LEGISLATORS
LEADERS TO TAKE THE COVERT
NINETEEN CRISIS SERIOUSLY. AND
THE LEGISLATURE DID TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY. FOR ITSELF. THE
CAPITAL WAS SHUT DOWN FOR
MONTHS STRICT PROTOCOLS WERE
FOLLOWED ALMOST ALL COMMITTEES
IN FOUR SESSIONS WERE CANCELED
WE'RE IN A BASKETBALL ARENA.
LEGISLATORS DID EVERYTHING
HUMANLY POSSIBLE TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. WELL LEAVING THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA BEREFT OF
THE FUNDAMENTAL PROTECTIONS THE
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT IS
SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE. AS GROSSLY
CROKES CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND
MILLIONS OF OTHER CALIFORNIANS
KEPT DOING THESE ESSENTIAL
JOBS. LEGISLATORS REFUSED TO DO
THERE'S OUR INSTITUTION
VANISHED DEEMING ITSELF IN
ESSENTIAL. WE SAT BACK AND
WATCHED AS GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM SEES THE LEGISLATIVE
POWER FOR HIMSELF. FALSELY
CLAIMING THAT A STATE OF
EMERGENCY NO MATTER HOW LONG IT
LASTS TRANSFORMS CALIFORNIA
INTO AN AUTOCRACY. END QUOTE
CENTRALIZES THE STATE'S POWERS
IN HIS HANDS. IMAGINE IF WE HAD
DONE THINGS DIFFERENTLY. IF WE
HAVE EARNED OUR PAYCHECKS IF WE
HAD STOOD OUR GROUND IF WE
DEFEND OUR CONSTITUTION. IF WE
HAD ROLLED UP OUR SLEEVES AND
MET THE CHALLENGES OF THIS YEAR
HAD ON. WE COULD HAVE BUILT UP
OUR HOSPITAL CAPACITY SUPPORTER
ARE HEALTH CARE WORKERS. AND
PROTECTED THE VULNERABLE. WE
COULD HAVE AVERTED THE EDT
TRAIN WRECK THAT IS KEPT FOOD
OFF THE TABLE OF MILLIONS. FROM
THE BEGINNING WE COULD HAVE
INSISTED ON DATA AND EVIDENCE
FOCUSED ON WHAT ACTUALLY MAKES
A DIFFERENCE AND AVOIDED THE
NEVER ENDING NO NOTHING
NIGHTMARE OF COLORS IN TWO
YEARS CURFEWS AND LOCKDOWNS
ATTESTATIONS AND EMERGENCY
BREAKS. WE COULD HAVE SAID. IF
YOU'RE GOING TO KEEP MILLIONS
OF KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL. WIDENING
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS STUNTING
DEVELOPMENT DAMAGING MENTAL
HEALTH CONCEALING ABUSE
DIMINISHING WHITE PROSPEX
SHORTENING LIFE EXPECTANCY YOU
BETTER HAVE A DARN GOOD REASON
FOR IT. WE COULD HAVE MANAGED
OUR STATE'S RESPONSE TOGETHER.
AS ONE PEOPLE. WITH A SHARED
FATE. INSTEAD OF REVERTING TO A
PRETTY MODERN SEPARATION OF THE
RULER AND THE RULED. WHEN I
ADDRESS THIS ASSEMBLY ON MARCH
SIXTEENTH. I SAID THE PARTISAN
RITUALS OF ORDINARY POLITICS
HAVE NO PLACE IN THESE
EXTRAORDINARY TIMES. I CALL
THEN ON EVERY LEGISLATOR IN
EVERY CALIFORNIAN REGARDLESS OF
POLITICAL PREFERENCE TO QUOTE
TRUST IN GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
LEADERSHIP AND LISTEN TO HIS
GUIDANCE. GAVIN NEWSOM MADE A
MOCKERY OF THAT TRUST. TAKE
YOUR POINT OF THE POINT OF
ORDER. WELL I DON'T WORKABLE.
WITH DUE RESPECT TO MY
COLLEAGUE I BELIEVE THAT
PERHAPS THE PREEMINENT
QUESTIONS AS FAR AS THE DEBATE
BETWEEN THE NEXT SPEAKER IS WHO
IS BEST SUITED TO STAND UP TO
OUR GOVERNOR AND TO RE INSERT
THE PREROGATIVES OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KILEY PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO THE NOMINATION.
WITHIN WEEKS GOVERNOR NEWSOM
HID FROM THE LEGISLATURE A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR NO BID CONTRACT
WITH THE POLITICAL ALLY.
OUTSOURCED THE MOST IMPORTANT
DECISIONS THE POWERFUL SPECIAL
INTERESTS AND STARTED TALKING
ABOUT THE CORONA VIRUS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A NEW
PROGRESSIVE ERA. AN OPPORTUNITY
TO RESHAPE THE WAY WE DO
pBUT AS THIS LEGISLATURE
WATCHED. THE OUTCOMES HAVE BEEN
ANYTHING BUT PROGRESSIVE. OUR
ECONOMY IS DOING ABOUT THE
WORST IN THE COUNTRY. OUR KIDS
IN POOR COMMUNITIES ARE FARING
WORST OF ALL OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
PERFORMANCE IS MIDDLING. WITH
THE BASIC PILLARS OF LIBERAL
DEMOCRACY DISMANTLED. OUR BODY
POLITIC IS DISENFRANCHISED. AND
DIVIDED EVEN THE HIGH PRIEST OF
DATA ANALYSIS NATE SILVER. JUST
REFERRED TO THE QUOTE.
IRRATIONAL AND NOT VERY SCIENCE
DRIVEN REGIME OF COVERT
POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA. THE
FACT IS OUR GOVERNOR HAS LOST
ALL CREDIBILITY WITH THE
PUBLIC. AND WHATEVER THE
SHORTCOMINGS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE. IN THIS MOMENT WE
HAVE ONE INHERENT ADVANTAGE. WE
ARE NOT GAVIN NEWSOM. IS A
KILEY YOUR TIME IS ON WE NEED
TO TAKE UP THE BATON THAT NEVER
SHOULD HAVE BEEN HANDED BACK
HANDED OFF IN THE FIRST PLACE
AND WORK TOGETHER TO REBUILD
TRUST AND FORGE A BETTER PATH
FORWARD AND THAT'S WHERE I
NOMINATE. THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FROM SAN DIEGO MARIE WALDRON
WHO I KNOW WAS PREPARED TO GET
WORKING. FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK MISTER KILEY
IS THEIR SECOND. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
DAVY SECONDED THE MOTION. ARE
THERE ANY FURTHER NOMINATIONS.
FEARING NINE NOMINATIONS ARE
NOW CLOSED FOR THE OFFICE THE
SPEAKER OF THE FAMILY IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE RULES
AND PRECEDENTS REQUIRING A
RECORDED ROLL CALL VOTE WILL BE
SUSPENDED TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ANTHONY RENDON TO BE EX.
SORRY TO BE ELECTED AS SPEAKER
FOR ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF
ANTHONY RENDON SAY I'D- FOR ALL
THOSE. IN FAVOR OF ELECTING
MARIE WALDRON PLEASE SAY I.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RENDON HAS IT
YOU ARE ELECTED CONGRATULATIONS
MISTER SPEAKER.
SPEAKER LET
RENDON IS APPROACH THE ROSTRUM
TO TAKE THE OATH.
OFFICE OF
SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY PLEASE
RAISE YOUR RIGHT HAND DO YOU
SOLEMNLY SWEAR THAT YOU WILL
SUPPORT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AGAINST
ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC. THAT WILL BEAR TRUE
FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY
TAKE THIS OBLIGATION FREELY
WITHOUT ANY MENTAL RESERVATION
OR PURPOSE OF EVASION. AND THAT
YOU WILL WELL AND FAITHFULLY
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES UPON WHICH
YOU'RE ABOUT TO ENTER IF SO
PLEASE AFFIRM YOUR- BY STATING
I DO. I DO. CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU. I WANT TO START BY
THANKING YOU FOR RE ELECTING ME
AS YOUR SPEAKER OFF HONORED TO
BE CHOSEN AGAIN FOR THIS OFFICE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO
RISE TO THE HONOR I WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A MEMBER SPEAKER
THAT IS WHY WHO CONSULTS WITH
MEMBERS AND MAKES DECISIONS FOR
THE BENEFIT. OF THE MEMBERSHIP.
IN ADDITION TO BEING REELECTED
SPEAKER I AM OF COURSE HONORED
THAT THE PEOPLE OF THE SIXTY
THIRD DISTRICT. HAVE CHOSEN ME
TO REPRESENT THEM AGAIN. REALLY
THOUGH. IT IS THE WORK OF THIS
BODY. THAT IS EARNING US THE
RIGHT TO CONTINUE TO REPRESENT
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. TODAY
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA MEANS
TREATING CO THAT SERIOUSLY. FOR
THAT REASON WE ARE MEETING FOR
ORGANIZATIONAL SESSION IN THIS
QUITE UNIQUE LOCATION. FOR THAT
SAME REASON WE ARE UNABLE TO
CELEBRATE THE NEW SESSION IN
THE PRESENCE OF OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS AND OUR FRIENDS. WE
MUST CONTINUE TO EXERCISE
MAXIMUM CAUTION IN ORDER TO
BRING THIS STATE THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC. FIVE YEARS AGO WHEN I
FIRST BECAME SPEAKER. I SPOKE
OF ESTABLISHING MY PRIORITIES
AS OVERSIGHT FIGHTING PART
POVERTY AND PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. SINCE THEN WE
HAVE DONE REMARKABLE THINGS TO
HELP OUR FELLOW CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE MOST IN NEED. WE'VE
EXPANDED THE AVAILABILITY OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD CARE TO LOW
INCOME WORKING FAMILIES. WE'VE
BOOSTED THE MINIMUM WAGE WE'VE
EXPANDED TUITION FREE OFFERINGS
IN HIGHER EDUCATION. AND WE'VE
MADE HEALTH CARE AVAILABLE TO
MORE CALIFORNIANS. IN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS ALSO
CONSISTENTLY PUSHED FORWARD ON
THE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION FRONT
THE TRUEST DEMOCRACY IS THAT
WERE MOST PEOPLE ARE ENGAGED.
WELL SOME STATES HAVE WORKED TO
DISENFRANCHISE THEIR CITIZENS
CALIFORNIA HAS MOVED TO PUT THE
BALLOT INTO THE HANDS OF MORE
ELIGIBLE VOTERS SINCE I BECAME
SPEAKER. THE VOTERS CHOICE ACT
MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR REGISTERED
VOTERS TO CAST THEIR BALLOTS
MORE RECENTLY. IN MORE PLACES.
I WOULD DOOR MOTOR VOTER LAW
MADE IT MADE SURE THAT ELIGIBLE
VOTERS WERE REGISTERED AND BY
PUTTING BALLOTS INTO THE HANDS
OF EVERY SINGLE VOTER AND BY
LETTING PEOPLE MAIL THOSE
BALLOTS WITHOUT POSTAGE. WE'VE
TAKENPUBLIC PARTICIPATION TO
NEW HEIGHTS. THESE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS ARE JUST ON THE
SUBJECTS I MENTIONED WHEN I
FIRST BECAME SPEAKER WE ARE OF
COURSE GONE FAR BEYOND THAT. WE
TOOK A DRAMATIC STEP FORWARD IN
THE FIELD OF PUBLIC SAFETY WHEN
WE ENACTED A BILL TO LIMIT
POLICE USE OF FORCE. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. IT WAS A
STRUGGLE TO GET THERE BUT I
THINK WE'RE ALL WELL AWARE THAT
WE HAVE TO KEEP MOVING FORWARD.
WE HAVE TO ESTABLISH GOALS ON
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION THAT
PEOPLE ONCE THOUGHT WERE
IMPOSSIBLE. AND WE CREATED
MECHANISMS THAT ALLOW US TO
WORK TOWARD ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. OUR HOUSE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN ESTABLISHING
FUNDING FOR OUR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE STOOD
TOGETHER TO PASS MORE
EMPLOYMENT PROTECTIONS FOR
EXPLOITED GIG WORKERS AND
OVERTIME FOR FARMWORKERS. THOSE
FARMWORKERS ARE STILL
CULTIVATING THE NATION'S FOOD
IN THE FACE OF HIGHER THAN
AVERAGE COVE INFECTION RATES.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE WORK WE HAVE DONE
TO GET OUR OWN HOUSE IN ORDER.
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
CALIFORNIA NATION EMBRACE THE
ME TOO MOVEMENT FOR POINTING
OUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
EXPLOITATION BY THOSE IN POWER.
THIS WAS A CALL FOR US TO
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR PAST
OPERATIONS WERE NOT ENOUGH. TO
END THE PRACTICE OF WORKPLACE
HARASSMENT THE CAPITAL. WE
EXPLORE ALL OUR PRACTICES AND
IN THE END WE CHANGED
EVERYTHING WE REFORM TRAINING
WE TOOK INVESTIGATION OUT OF
PARTISAN CONTROL WE ADOPTED POP
POLICIES THAT ARE INTENDED. NOT
JUST TO PUNISH BUT ALSO TO
ALLOW STAFF AND MEMBERS TO
LEARN FROM EXPERIENCE. I AM
PROUD OF OUR WORK IN THIS AREA
JUST AS I AM PROUD THAT THE
ASSEMBLY HASIL REACHED THE
LANDMARK A GENDER PAY PARITY
FOR OUR STAFF. WE WORKED HARD
ON THAT JUST AS WE WORKED HARD
TO GET WOMEN ELECTED AND TO
HAVE WOMEN APPOINTED AS
COMMITTEE CHAIRS IN FACT SINCE
I TOOK OVER THE SPEAKERSHIP IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I HAVEN'T
I HAVE BEEN THE NUMBER OF WE
CHAIRS MORE THE DOUBLE. WE ALSO
NAMED. AND WILL OF COLOR TO.
THAT HAVE NO HAD WOMEN AS
LEADERS BUT- INCLUDING A
AMERICA WOMEN IN BOTH SHE SARGE
LET'S JUST COUNCIL AND AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN AS CHIEF
CLERK. AND TODAY WE CELEBRATE
ANOTHER NEW FIRST AS ELOISE
GOMEZ REYES BECOMES THE BODY'S
FIRST LATINA MAJORITY LEADER.
STILL WE NEED TO DO MORE. TO
THAT END JUST THIS PAST MONTH I
HIRED A DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION CONSULTANT TO EXAMINE
THE ASSEMBLY IS POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES SO WE CAN ACHIEVE
GREATER EQUITY AND INCLUSION. I
WOULD ALSO LOVE TO STAND BEFORE
YOU AND SAY THAT OUR POLICY
EFFORTS AND ACCOMPLISHMENTS
HAVE BROUGHT COMPLETE EQUITY TO
OUR STATE. AND ALLOWED US TO
SOLVE THE POVERTY PUZZLE
CALIFORNIA BUT WE KNOW THAT'S
NOT THE CASE. WE KNOW THAT IN
THE PAST SEVERAL DECADES THE
ECONOMIC GAPS HAVE GROWN WIDER
IN THIS COUNTRY AND IN
CALIFORNIA. NOW DESPITE A
BOOMING STOCK MARKET THOSE ARE
LOWER TIERS ARE STILL FACING AN
ECONOMIC STRUGGLE AS KOBE
DRIVES MORE AND MORE AND MORE
CALIFORNIANS TO OUR PROPERTY. A
QUARTER MILLION AMERICANS HAVE
DIED FROM CODED IN CALIFORNIA
THE TOTAL STANDS ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND. IT IS TRUE THAT THE
LAST TIME WE MET IN SACRAMENTO
IS THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY BACK
IN AUGUST WE WERE ALREADY
FACING THE NEW AND TERRIBLE
DEMANDS PRESENTED BY A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. THE PAST FEW MONTHS
AWAY FROM SACRAMENTO HAVE GIVEN
US THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROCESS
THE EXPERIENCE OF WORKING UNDER
PANDEMIC RESTRICTIONS. I WILL
ASK YOU TODAY TO USE THAT
EXPERIENCE TO FOCUS THIS BODIES
VISION FOR THE FUTURE. THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE NEW TO THE ASSEMBLY
CONGRADULATIONS YOU WILL NOW
HELP US TO FACE THAT CHALLENGE.
WE KNOW THAT WE CANNOT
LEGISLATE COBIT AWAY BUT WE CAN
USE CO THAT IS A LENDS FOR
CHANGING THE WAY WE LOOK AT HOW
WE LEGISLATE. AS A RESULT OF
CODE WE HAVE SEEN ALL THESE
THINGS WE'VE SEEN IN YEARS I
NEED TO PROTECT PEOPLE IN DIRE
CIRCUMSTANCES FROM BEING
EVICTED. WE'VE SEEN A NEED TO
PROVIDE GREATER UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS IN CRISIS SITUATIONS.
WE'VE SEEN AN UPSURGE IN RACIAL
TENSIONS AND BIGOTRY. AS
SEGMENTS OF OUR POPULATION ARE
UNFAIRLY SINGLED OUT AND
IGNORANTLY BLAMED FOR STARTING
OR SPREADING THE VIRUS. AND
WE'VE SEEN A NEED TO PROTECT
EVERY INDIVIDUAL'S HOUSE. IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
THE COMMUNITY. WE HAVE SEEN THE
VIRUS AMPLIFIED LONG STANDING
HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
NATIVE AMERICANS BLACKS LATINOS
NATIVE HAWAIIAN. AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS. CARBON SHOULD
TEACHERS THAT AN INDIVIDUAL'S
LACK OF ECONOMIC MEANS IS NOT
THE SAME AS A LACK OF CHARACTER.
NOW MORE THAN EVER LET US
REMEMBER THE SOCIAL CONTRACT.
IT SHOULD INFORM HOW WE BEHAVE
AT ALL TIMES. CALIFORNIA SHOULD
BE UNITED AGAINST POVERTY AT
ALL TIMES NOT JUST WHEN WE'RE
AT WAR WITH CODE. SOON THERE
WILL BE A KEY CHANGE THAT WE
CAN COUNT ON I BELIEVE IN OUR
FAVOR THAT IS THE UPCOMING
CHANGE OF FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIONS. ALTHOUGH THERE
WILL SURELY BE A DISAGREEMENT
FROM A FEW OF OUR COLLEAGUES I
BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL BE A
VERY GOOD CHANGE FOR EVERY
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA. IT WILL
BE A REMARKABLE THING TO HAVE A
CALIFORNIAN ADVOCATING FOR US.
A CALIFORNIA WHO HAS EXPERIENCE
IN STATE GOVERNMENT. AND HAS
ALREADY WORKED ON OUR BEHALF
AND CONGRESS. SHE IS A
CALIFORNIAN WHO REPRESENTS THE
RICHEST OF OUR DIVERSE NATION
SHE'S THE FIRST WOMAN THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND THE FIRST
SOUTH ASIAN VICE PRESIDENT IN
US HISTORY. FOUR YEARS AGO WHEN
THE OUTGOING PRESIDENT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE. I URGE US TO STAY
FOCUSED ON THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA. IT WAS BY FOCUSING
ON THE ISSUES THROUGH OUR
PRISON THAT I SAID WE COULD
SUCCEED. FOCUSING ON CALIFORNIA
REMAINS THE RIGHT STRATEGY THIS
TIME WE WILL NOT FACE
OPPOSITION AT EVERY STEP WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT THINGS THAT THE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS CARE
ABOUT. THINGS LIKE CLIMATE
CHANGE ACCESS TO EDUCATION AT
ALL LEVELS INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS
WOMEN'S RIGHTS HEALTH CARE FAIR
TREATMENT FOR IMMIGRANTS. BUT
WE STILL NEED TO IDENTIFIED
CALIFORNIA'S PRIORITIES AND WE
WILL STILL NEED TO COMMUNICATE
THOSE PRIORITIES TO THE WHITE
HOUSE. PRESIDENT BIDEN OF
COURSE WILL HAVE MANY MORE
PEOPLE SEEKING HIS HERE BESIDE
US. I'M EANWHILE INTENT TO
CONTINUE LISTENING TO YOU AS WE
CHART OUR COURSE. I THINK
INTENDED TO CONTINUE INSURING
THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBERS HAVE POWER
TO PURSUE THEIR POLICY GOALS.
SIX S. IN THE COMING SESSION
WILL DEPEND ON THAT
COLLABORATION BUT WILL ALSO
TAKE A FOCUS ON SOME KEY
ISSUES. ONE OF THOSE ISSUES
THIS POLICE TO CERTIFICATION.
THIS IS A CONTINUATION OF OUR
DRIVE TO MAKE PUBLIC SAFETY IN
CALIFORNIA TRULY ABOUT THE
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC KNOCKED
OUT OF ANY SPECIAL INTEREST.
YOU AND I DO NOT HAVE IMMUNITY
FOR OUR BEHAVIOR OUR
MISBEHAVIOR. IN FACT WE ARE
UNDER INTENSE SCRUTINY. BRITNEY
IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS WHO
CALIFORNIANS TRUST WITH OUR
LIVES. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
THEY DO NOT HAVE IMMUNITY FOR
THEIR TRANSGRESSIONS I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT MISTAKES I'M
TALKING ABOUT LIFE AND DEATH
MISDEEDS. POLICE TO
CERTIFICATION IS ABOUT
PROTECTING GOOD PEOPLE FROM BAD
BEHAVIOR AND WE NEED TO SEE
THAT POLICY ENACTED IN THE
CURRENT SESSION. CALIFORNIA
ALSO MUST BUILD ON THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING ON CLIMATE
CHANGE THERE IS NO QUESTION
THAT WE ARE ALREADY A NATIONAL
LEADER WITH AMBITIOUS PLANS TO
CONDUCT CONTROLLED GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. AND CHANGE THE
MODELS FOR OUR ENERGY ECONOMY
BUT THAT ISN'T ENOUGH. I WANTED
TO PUSH HARDER TO KEEP THAT
PROGRESS MOVING FORWARD. THIS
IS SOMETHING MADE EVEN MORE
URGENT BY ANOTHER RECORD
BREAKING YEAR OF WILDFIRES.
THOSE FIRES PUT IMMENSE
QUANTITIES OF CARBON INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE THAT'S TRUE WE KNOW
THAT. SOME OF YOU HAVE ALREADY
HEARD ME POINT OUT THAT IT IS
NOT AN EXCUSE TO RELAX ON
GREENHOUSE GASES CAUSED BY
HUMANS. NEGLECTING THE IMPACTS
VEHICLES AND FACTORIES AND
ENERGY GENERATION CREATED THAT
NIGHTMARES FIRE CONDITIONS WE
EXPERIENCED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
OUR MISSION TO RAISE
TEMPERATURES AND WRECKED HAVOC
WITH RAINFALL TOO LITTLE HERE
TOO MUCH IN HURRICANE REGIONS.
MORE DISASTER IS INEVITABLE IF
WE DON'T CONTROL EMISSIONS. IT
MAY BE TRUE THAT WE CANNOT
SOLVE CLIMATE CHANGE ACTING
ALONE IN CALIFORNIA BUT DON'T
FORGET CALIFORNIANS ARE LEADERS
SINCE THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
CALIFORNIA GOVERNORS AND
LEGISLATORS OF BOTH PARTIES
HAVE CREATED SOLUTIONS FOR
CLEAN AIR AND WATER. OTHER
STATES A NATIONAL MINISTRATIONS
HAVE FOLLOWED AND SO HAS
INDUSTRY. THERE IS SOMETHING
ELSE THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
MODEL AND THAT IS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
MEANS TWO THINGS FIRST IT MEANS
THAT OUR ENVIRONMENTAL ACTIONS
BENEFIT ALL COMMUNITIES. AND
THAT WE'RE DEVOTING EQUAL
ATTENTION TO POLLUTION AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
PROVIDING ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS LIKE PARKS AND TRAILS
AND BIKE PATHS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. SECOND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE MEANS
THAT THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF
GREEN INDUSTRY ACCRUE TO THOSE
WHO NEED THE MOST. AS WE
LEGISLATE TO MOVE TO A CLEANER
ECONOMY WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
ECONOMIC INEQUALITY DOES NOT
GROW. CALIFORNIA CAN NOT PUT
THE BRAKES ON CARBON GENERATING
INDUSTRIES WITHOUT HAVING A
STRATEGY TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA'S WORKING IN THOSE
INDUSTRIES. LIKEWISE. WHY WHY
DO WE NEED TO GUARANTEE THAT
THE PEOPLE OF LOWER INCOME
DISTRICTS LIKE MINE ARE
BENEFICIARIES OF CALIFORNIANS
INVESTMENTS IN SUSTAINABLE
SOLUTIONS WE NEED TO RAISE
THOSE INEQUITIES BOTH IN JOBS
AND ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS. I
HAVE A THIRD GOAL A GOAL THAT I
KNOW WE SHARED WITH OTHERS IN
THIS ROOM. AND ACTIVISTS THAT'S
THE EXPANSION OF BROADBAND
SERVICES. OUR WORLD TODAY IS
DEPENDENT ON THE INTERNET
PROBABLY MORE THAN EVER
DEPENDED ON TELEPHONE SERVICE.
AS WE RETREATED TO OUR HOUSES
TO SLOW THE SPREAD OF CARE OF
THE PEOPLE BECAME DEPENDENT ON
HOME ACCESS FOR EVERY FACET OF
THEIR LIVES. WE SAW UNEVEN
DISTRIBUTION OF INTERNET ACCESS
WHEN CALIFORNIA SCHOOL CHILDREN
WERE ABLE TO GET ONLINE
INSTRUCTION. WE SAW THAT ACCESS
WAS NOT UNIVERSAL WHEN PEOPLE
IN WILDFIRE REGIONS WERE UNABLE
TO GET EMERGENCY UPDATES THAT
WERE LITERALLY MATTERS OF LIFE
AND DEATH. THIS IS NOT JUST A
QUESTION OF RICH AND POOR. ANY
OF OUR RURAL CALIFORNIANS ARE
UNABLE TO CONNECT TO THIS
UTILITY THAT PROVIDES
INFORMATION EDUCATION
ENTERTAINMENT MEDICAL ACCESS
AND WILDFIRE INFORMATION.
CALIFORNIA'S INCREDIBLE HUB FOR
NEW TECHNOLOGY AND YET MANY OF
OUR RESIDENTS FIND THEMSELVES
LEFT OUT OF BASIC INTERNET
ACCESS. WE NEED TO TACKLE
EXPANSION OF BROADBAND ACCESS
NOW IT HAS TO HAPPEN THIS
SESSION. THESE ARE ALL
CALIFORNIA PRIORITIES THEY'RE
THE THINGS THAT THE PEOPLE OF
THIS STATE NEEDS. I'M ALSO
MINDFUL OF THE CHALLENGES WE
FACE. WE COULD TALK OVER THE
BARRIER TO GETTING WORK DONE WE
COULD CALL CODED AND IT'S- THE
ATTENDANT. FISCAL SITUATION AS
A BARRIER TO GETTING WORK DONE
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO DO THAT.
THEY ARE SUBSTANTIAL CHALLENGES
FOR CERTAIN BUT THEY'RE NOT
GREATER THAN THE CHALLENGES
CALIFORNIANS HAVE FACED
THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY. OUR
CHALLENGES INCLUDED THOSE OF
NATIVE THE NATIVE AMERICANS WHO
SUFFER FROM DISEASE AND
MASSACRES. THEY INCLUDED THE
CHALLENGES OF SOUTHEAST ASIANS
WHO FLED VIOLENCE LIKE MY WIFE
AND HIS FAMILY OR WORKING CLASS
MEXICAN SEEKING OPPORTUNITY
LIKE MY OWN FAMILY. WE HAVE
BUILT. TODAY'S CALIFORNIA
COLLECTIVELY BY FACING THOSE
CHALLENGES. I AM CONFIDENT WE
CAN FACE TODAY'S CHALLENGES.
AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN
DO EVEN MORE. I WILL NOT TAKE
COVIDIEN ARE UNCERTAIN REVENUE
PICTURE AS AN EXCUSE TO SAY WE
HAVE TO DO WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
FEWER RESOURCES WITH FEWER
OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE WHEN THE
STATE HAS LESS THAT'S A TIME
WHEN PEOPLE HURT. MOST THAT'S
THE TIME WHEN WE HAVE TO DO
MORE FOR CALIFORNIANS. THIS IS
POSSIBLE IF WE MAKE THEM OUR
PRIORITY INSTEAD OF GIVING THEM
WHAT'S LEFT OVER. I THINK WE'RE
MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION. WE
THOUGHT WHEN WE PASSED ONE OF
THE MOST DIFFICULT BUDGETS IN A
DECADE EARLIER THIS YEAR. IT
WAS ONE OF MY PROUDEST MOMENTS
THE SPEAKER. WE MAKE SURE THAT
THE BUDGET TOOK CARE OF SENIOR
PROGRAMS IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND
NUTRITION PROGRAMS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES. LET US FOCUS ON
CALIFORNIA'S LIFE BUT IT'S
COMMON PEOPLE. INSTEAD OF ON
THOSE WHO PROFIT FROM THEIR
SWEAT. BY SUPPORTING OUR
WORKERS OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
CHILDREN WE WILL REBUILD
CALIFORNIA'S PROSPERITY. WITH
HELP FROM OUR PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT ELECT WITH HELP
FROM A SUPPORT OF CONGRESS I
HOPE. WITH THE COLLABORATION OF
OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE STATE
SENATE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I
WENT THE HOPES OF FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS AS MOTIVATION WE
WILL MAKE TWENTY TWENTY ONE A
YEAR OF SEIZING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR HEALING. FOR JUSTICE AND
FOR BUILDING A STRONGER FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS THE APPOINTMENT OF
THE SPEAKER PRO TEM I AM
APPOINTING KEVIN MULLIN OF THE
TWENTY SECOND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
TO THIS OFFICE WE WILL
ADMINISTER THE OATH AFTER WE
TAKE UP OUR ORGANIZATIONAL
RESOLUTIONS. BUT LET'S CHEER
FOR KEVIN NOW. MEMBERS THERE
ARE SEVERAL RESOLUTIONS AT THE
ASSEMBLY DESK THERE ARE HARD
COPIES ON EACH OF YOUR TABLES
WE WILL FIRST ADOPTER HOUSE
RULES BECAUSE WE ARE NOT USING
THE ELECTRONIC VOTING SYSTEM
TODAY WE WILL TAKE AN ORAL ROLL
CALL VOTE ON ORGANIZATIONAL
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME SINCE THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES AT THE ASSEMBLY IS
USING ORACLE OR WILL ROLL CALL
THE TIME LEGISLATION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KEN COOLEY. I WILL
PRESENT HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD
READING THE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY RELATIVE
TO THE STANDING RULES OF THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO REGULAR SESSION.
GOOD AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES IN
KEEPING WITH THIS DAY. HOUSE
RESOLUTION ONE MAINTAINS
FIDELITY. TO THE PAST OF THIS
INSTITUTION. ANOTHER LACK
NONETHELESS REFLECTS. THE
IMPACT OF PANDEMIC. A HOUSE
RESOLUTION ONE ESTABLISHES A
STANDARD RULES IS SIMPLY FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SESSION. IT INCLUDES
VARIOUS CHANGES TO THE STANDARD
RULES THAT WERE IN PLACE PRIOR
TO THE DURING THE PRIOR SESSION.
THESE RULES CHANGE CHANGES IN
DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE
CHALLENGES POSED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND PROVIDE THE
ASSEMBLY THE NECESSARY
FLEXIBILITY TO OPERATE AS THE
PANDEMIC PROCESS SOME OF THE
CHANGES THE STANDARD RULES
INCLUDE. CREATION OF A NEW
STANDING COMMITTEE THE
COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT. RENAMING TO
EXISTING COMMITTEES ELECTIONS
AND REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE
BECOMES ELECTIONS COMMITTEE AND
THE VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
BECOMES A MILITARY AND VETERANS
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE. THESE RULES
ALLOW REFERRALS AND REFERRALS
TO OCCUR OF THE ASSEMBLY IS IN
RECESS DURING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY DUE TO PANDEMIC VERY
SPECIFICALLY TIED TO THAT
DECLARATION OF EMERGENCY.
ALLOWING INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS
OR HEARINGS ON RESOLUTIONS
DURING DEADLINE WEEKS WHEN
COMMITTEE HEARINGS ARE
GENERALLY NOT ALLOWED. ALLOWING
COMMITTEES TO SET BILLS FOR
HEARING PENDING REFERRAL IF
AUTHORIZED BY THE SPEAKER. WITH
YOUR AUTHORIZATION PRINT IN THE
JOURNAL. THE USUAL OF CLARIFY
THE LONGSTANDING CUSTOM AND
PRACTICE RELATIVE TO FILE
NOTICE WAIVERS ON A CHECK IN
SESSION DAY. AND ALSO ALLOWING
FARMERS WAIVERS WHEN THE
ASSEMBLY IS IN RECESS. ALLOWING
BILLS BE AMENDED WITH THE
ASSEMBLY IS IN RECESS OF
REQUESTED BY THE CHAIRPERSON OF
THE STANDING COMMITTEE TO
FACILITATE- UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
BILL CONTAINS AND DIALOGUE ON
IT WHICH IS OUR DUTY. PROVIDED
THE BILL'S A SUBSTANTIAL FOR
MEMBERS PROPOSED BY THE AUTHOR
OF THE FORMER MANAGER. ONLY
WHICH IS TO SAY ONLY BY THE
AUTHOR OR THE FOR MANAGER.
MAYBE RE REFER TO POLICY
CREATES PURSUANT TO SEVEN SEVEN
POINT TWO. PRODUCTS FOR SESSION
WHEN A STATE OF EMERGENCY JUST
TO THE PANDEMIC ANOTHER RULES
CHANGE FACILITATE DISCUSSION OF
SOME OF THE PROPOSALS IN THE
RIGHT SETTING. ALLOWING AUTHORS
ARE FOREIGNERS WHICH PROVIDE
WRITTEN NOTICE OF THEIR
INTENTION TO REMOVE A BILL FOR
AN ACT OF FILE ON A CHECK IN
SESSION TODAY. WITH THE NO
SCREEN PROVIDED BY THE CHIEF
CLERK. TO THE SPEAKER AND
REPUBLICAN LEADER. THESE RULES
WILL ENSURE THE ASSEMBLY
OPERATE SMOOTHLY AND
EFFICIENTLY AS WE CONTINUE TO
CONFRONT THE COVERT NINETEEN.
PANDEMICAGAIN I SAY THESE ARE
RULES WITH REFLECT FIDELITY TO
OUR PAST. BUT ADJUSTED FOR THE
CIRCUMSTANCE WE FIND OURSELVES
IN. AND EVER. RESPECT FOR
QUESTIONABLE. THANK YOU MISTER
ROAD MEMBERS IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK ON HR ONE PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO THE MEMBERS PODIUM.
TO BE RECOGNIZED AFTER. AFTER
THE PODIUM IS GOING. THANK YOU
MISTER GOING. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I WE WITHHOLD ENOUGH
CONSENT AND ASK FOR A ROLL CALL
VOTE. NICE EVERYBODY ELSE WAS
TO SPEAK. ALL THE BAIT HAVING
SEES MR COOLEY YOU MAY CLOSE. I
REQUEST ARRIVAL. THANK YOU MR
COOLEY WE WILL TAKE AN ORAL
CALL THE NATURE WHEN THE REST
THIS RESOLUTION REQUIRES FORTY
ONE VOTES MEMBERS AFTER THE
COURT BECAUSE YOUR NAME PLEASE
CAST YOUR VOTE MY CLEARLY
SAYING I OR NO. THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY HI ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA HI BARRICADE HAND.
BARRICADE HAN HI BENNETT.
BENNETT HI BERMAN. BERMAN HI
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO BLOOM.
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HI BONTA. BONTA
HI BURKE. BURKE CALDERON.
CALDERON HI CARILLO. CARILLO HI
CERVANTES. CERVANTES HI CHANNEL.
SHELL ON A JUNE. GEN NO CHIU.
CHIU HI CHOI. CHOI NO COOLEY.
COOLEY HI COOPER. COOPER HI
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NO DALLY.
DALLY NO DALY. DALY HI DAVIES.
DAVIES NO- FLORA. LARA NO PHONE.
FONG NO FRAZIER. FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN HI GABRIEL.
GABRIEL HI GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
NO CRISTINA GARCIA. CRISTINA
GARCIA HI EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA HI GIPSON.
GIPSON HI GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HI
GRAY. GRAY HI GRAYSON. GRAYSON
ARI HOLDEN. HOLDEN HI IRWIN.
IRWIN HI JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER HI KALRA. KALRA HI
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER HI. KILEY.
KILEY NO LACKEY. LACKEY NO LEVY.
LEE HI LEVINE. LEVINE HI LOW.
LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN HI MATHIS. MATHIS
NO MAYES. MAYES ARI MCCARTY.
MCCARTY RD MEDINA. MEDINA HI
MULLIN. MULLIN HI MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHIHI THE SYRIAN. THE
SYRIAN ARMY WHEN. WHEN NO
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL HI
PATTERSON. PATTERSON NO
PETRIE-NORRIS. PETRIE-NORRIS HI
QUIRK. QUIRK HI KIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI RAMOS. RAMOS HI
RAY IS. RAILS HI THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS HI RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ HI RUBIO. RUBIO SALAS.
SALAS HI SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO ON
C. R. TO. C. R. TWO NO SMITH.
SMITH NO STONE. STONE OUR TEAM.
THING HI VALIDATORS. BALLADARES
NO V. UP WHO'D WANNA. THE
APPROVED WELL HI VOEPEL. VOEPEL
NO WALDRON. WALDRON NO WARD.
MORE HI WEBER. WEBER WICKS.
WICKS WOOD. WOOD HI MISTER
SPEAKER HI MISTER SPEAKER HI.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED FIFTY
SIX EYES AND NINETEEN KNOWS.
MAJORITY LEADER RAY S. WILL
PRESENT HOUSE RESOLUTION TO FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ADOPTION THE
CLERK WILL READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION TO HOUSE RESOLUTION
TWO BY ASSEMBLY SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON RELATIVE TO THE ELECTION
OF OFFICERS OF THE ASSEMBLY FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO REGULAR SESSION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER S. YOU MAY OPEN. MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I OFFER
HOUSE RESOLUTION TO ON BEHALF
OF SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON TO
DESIGNATE THE NON MEMBER
OFFICERS OF THE ASSEMBLY FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO REGULAR SESSION. THEY ARE
SUPER ARDER AS CHIEF CLERK.
POLICE SAID BUCKLEY S. CHIEF
SERGEANT AT ARMS. IMAM MUHAMMAD
YASIR KHAN IS CHAPLAIN. THERE
ANY QUESTIONABLE NATURE TO. ALL
THE DAY HAVING CEASED NOT A
MAJORITY LEADER YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON H. R. TWO WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL SUBSTITUTE
THE ATTENDANCE ROLL CALL FOR
THE VOTE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
NO OBJECTION THE VOTE IT IS.
SEVENTY FIVE I ZERO KNOWS THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED AS PARKER
IS BUCKLEY IMAM YASIR PLEASE
COME FORWARD TO THE ROSTER FOR
THE OATH OF OFFICE MAJORITY
LEADERS OUT MAJORITY LEADER
ELOISE RASCAL ADMINISTER THE
OATH OF OFFICE TO THE NON
MEMBER OFFICERS MAJORITY LEADER
S. MISS PARKER. MS BUCKLEY.
IMAM YES SIR. YES SIR. PLEASE
COME. FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
CHIEF CLERK. SHE STARTED AT
ARMS AND CHAPLAIN RESPECTIVELY
PLEASE RAISE YOUR RIGHT HAND.
DO YOU SOLEMNLY SWEAR THAT YOU
WILL SUPPORT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC THE TWO WILL BEAR TRUE
FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
YOU TAKE THE OBLIGATION FREE
LINK WITHOUT ANY MENTAL MENTAL
RESERVATION OR PURPOSE OF
EVASION. AND THAT YOU WILL WELL
AND FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE THE
DUTIES UPON WHICH YOU ARE ABOUT
TO ENTER IF SO PLEASE AFFIRM
YOUR OATH BY STATING I DO.
CONGRATULATIONS.
MAJORITY
LEADER REST WILL PRESENT HOUSE
RESOLUTION THREE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIRD READING HOUSE
RESOLUTION THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ HOUSE RESOLUTION THREE BY
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON
RELATIVE TO THE ORGANIZATION OF
THE ASSEMBLY FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO REGULAR
SESSION. MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
HOUSE RESOLUTION THREE AS A
ROUTINE HOUSEKEEPING RESOLUTION
WHICH DOES THE FOLLOWING. IT
AUTHORIZES THE RULES COMMITTEE
CHIEF CLERK AND SERJEANT AT
ARMS TO RECEIVE WARRANTS FROM
THE CONTROLLER TO PAY MEMBERS
OFFICERS AND STAFF OF THE
ASSEMBLY. IT ALSO REQUIRES A
CHIEF CLERK TO PROVIDE COPIES
OF THE ASSEMBLY WEEKLY
HISTORIES TO STEP SPECIFIED
GOVERNMENT OFFICES AND
ACCREDITED NEWSPAPERS.
NEWSPAPER REPRESENTATIVES AND
SPECIFIES THE DURING THE
ORGANIZATIONAL RECESS NO BILL
CAN BE INTRODUCED AT THE DESK
EXCEPT BY PERSON DESIGNATED IN
WRITING BY THE MEMBER AND THAT
THE DESIGNATION BE FILED WITH
THE CHIEF CLERK. THREE QUESTION
SURVEY ON HR. THREE ALL DAY
HAVING CEASED MAJORITY LEADER
ESTIMATE BECAUSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THREE I VOTE ON H. R. THREE
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
SUBSTITUTE THE ATTENDANCE ROLL
CALL FOR THE VOTE ON THIS ITEM.
NO OBJECTION- NO OBJECTION THE
VOTE IS. A SEVENTY FIVE AYES
ZERO KNOWS THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS THEIR LETTERS
AT THE DESK NAMING THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE DEMOCRATIC
AND REPUBLICAN CAUCUSES WHO
WILL SERVE FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO REGULAR
SESSION WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
LETTERS WILL BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. OUR NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS THE OATH OF OFFICE
FOR PRE SPEAKER PRO TEM ELECT
KEVIN MULLIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN PLEASE APPROACH THE
ROSTRUM OUR CHIEF BURKE WITH
MINISTER THE.
KEVIN MULLIN FOR
THE- THE SPEAKER- THE BOB IS
FOR SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE
ASSEMBLY PLEASE AISE YOUR
RIGHT HAND. DO YOU SOLEMNLY
SWEAR THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT AND
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC. THEY WILL BEAR TRUE
FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE CONSTITUTION THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DO YOU TAKE
THIS OBLIGATION FREELY WITHOUT
ANY MENTAL RESERVATION OR
PURPOSE OF EVASION. AND THAT
WILL WELL AN FAITHFULLY
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES UPON WHICH
YOU'RE ABOUT TO ENTER IF SO.
PLEASE AFFIRM YOUR OATH BY
STATING I DO I DO
CONGRADULATIONS. SPEAKER PRO
TEM MAULING. WE HAD AN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHIEF BURKE THANK YOU
MEMBERS THERE IS A RESOLUTION
AT THE DEATHS RELATIVE TO THE
APPOINTMENT OF LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL MOVE TO THAT ITEM NOW.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NUMBER ONE BY SENATOR UMBERG
CORKERY. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE BY CENTER- BURKE
RELATIVE TO THE SELECTION OF
THE LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA. THAT A MAJORITY
LEADER YOU MAY OPEN. MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS S. C. R. ONE
RELATES TO THE SELECTION OF
KERA A. L. L. JENKINS AS A
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIANS. IN THIS ROLE SHE
WILL OVERSEE A STAFF OF OVER
FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES WHO
PROVIDE EXPERT NONPARTISAN
LEGAL AND TECHNICAL SERVICES TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
SHE IS A DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL WAS SERVED IN THE
OFFICE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. MS JENKINS HAS ADVISED
MEMBERS AND STAFF ON
LEGISLATIVE PROCEDURE
APPROPRIATIONS THE STATE BUDGET
THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR ELECTION
LAW. LITIGATION AND PERSONNEL
ISSUES AMONG OTHERS. I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
REYES ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OR DEBATE ON S. C. R. ONE.
SECONDARY NON THIS MAJORITY
LEADER YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON S. C. R. ONE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL SUBSTITUTE
THE ATTENDANCE ROLL CALL FOR
THE VOTE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
NO OBJECTION VOTERS I SEVENTY
FIVE KNOWS ZERO THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS THERE ARE
THREE LETTERS OF THE DESK
RELATIVE TO TODAY'S
ORGANIZATIONAL SESSION WITHOUT
OBJECTION THOSE LETTERS WILL BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MEMBERS
THIS IS BEEN A CHALLENGING YEAR
FOR ALL OF US TO SAY THE LEAST.
THE SUPPORT OF OUR FAMILIES HAS
BEEN VITAL TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR FAMILIES WE
HAVE A BRIEF SLIDESHOW THAT'S
ROLE THAT NOW.
LAURIE YOUR
FAMILY AND FRIENDS IN THE
SEVENTY THIRD ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
ARE SO PROUD OF YOU WE KNOW
THAT YOU WILL DO A TERRIFIC JOB
REPRESENTING.
US GO GET.
THE
WIFE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER ELECT
THURSTON SMITTY SMITH AND I
JUST WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO CONGRATULATE AND
CELEBRATE. ON THIS NEWS DAPPER.
IS UP FOR THE TASK IS GOING TO
DO A GREAT JOB. I ALSO WANT TO
TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO THINK
OUR FAMILY AND FRIENDS. FOR
THEIR LOVE AND SUPPORT THROUGH
THIS INTEMPERATE. IT MEANS THE
WORLD TO US. REGULATIONS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN VOTERS. AN
INTERESTING AND SOMETIMES
CHALLENGING JOURNEY BUT DON'T
FORGET EDUCATION THIS.
INSPIRATION FOR MOST. AND CRIED
TO BE A PART I KNOW YOU CAN BE
REVERSED. ON. NUMBER RIGHT.
YOUR MOM SIBLINGS AND I ARE
PROUD AND HAPPY FOR YOU CAN MY
HAS.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
AFTER RETURN FLOOR SESSION
TODAY MEMBERS WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE THEIR
FIRST LEGISLATIVE MEASURES BACK
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER AT THE
CAPITOL I AM ORDERING THE
DEATHS REMAIN OPEN TODAY UNTIL
FOUR PM FOR BILL INTRODUCTIONS.
IN THE ORGANIZATIONAL RECESS
THE DESK WILL BE OPEN FROM NINE
AM TO FOUR PM DAILY UNTIL
FRIDAY DECEMBER EIGHTEENTH. FOR
THE PURPOSE OF BILL
INTRODUCTIONS. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SPEAKER'S REMARKS
TODAY WILL BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. ON BEHALF OF THE
SPEAKER AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THIS ASSEMBLY I WOULD LIKE TO
EXTEND OUR THANKS TO THE GOLDEN
ONE CENTER. AND ALL OF THE
ASSEMBLY STAFF ASSEMBLED IN THE
REAR THAT WORK AROUND THE CLOCK
ON SHORT NOTICE TO MAKE THIS
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED
MEETING A SUCCESS TODAY LET'S
GIVE THEM ALL AROUND OF
APPLAUSE. MEMBERS WE HAVE
COMPLETED THE ORGANIZATIONAL
TASKS FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO REGULAR SESSION.
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION
TODAY WE WILL BEGIN OUR
ORGANIZATIONAL RECESS. THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
MONDAY EIGHT JANUARY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I
AM READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN THE SPEAKER MOVES
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS. THAT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY JANUARY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AT ONE PM.
AND THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.